foreign
the demand for business analyst is
dramatically increasing these
professionals are one of the highest
paid today however this process takes
some drastic steps we will learn in
detail about this in this video but
before moving forward please make sure
you subscribe to Simply learns YouTube
channel and press the Bell icon to never
miss any updates so what's in it for you
firstly we will learn about who is a
business analyst skills required to
become one after that roadmap to become
business analyst roles and
responsibility of a business analyst in
an organization and finally salary and
available jobs in the field of business
analysts if you are a fresher in the
field of business analyst then we have a
best offer for you please check out the
business analyst Master course in the
description below
who is a business analyst business
analysts have a key role in the
organization performing Financial
operations they are indirectly
responsible for creating economic growth
in the organization the action and
decision taken by the business analyst
will impact on the growth of the
organization a business analyst is
responsible for processing analyzing the
products and services to make profitable
decision to improve the financial
activities of the organization the role
of the business analyst is to make money
for the organization and handle all the
requirements demanded by the clients and
convey it to the product development
team now it's time to learn skills
required to become a successful business
analyst
analytical skills and critical thinking
great Achievers are the great thinkers
the role of business analyst comes in
the beginning of software development
life cycle which is requirement
Gathering I repeat a business analyst
must analyze a client's requirement
effectively critical thinking helps the
analyst in examining different
situations and providing a solution next
comes communication skill every role
demands communication skills but
communication is the key for every
business analyst they are supposed to
have a talk with every stakeholder a
good business analyst needs to have
communication in different phases be it
with clients product development team
implementation team for instance if a
product needs to be implemented then it
is the duty of a business analyst to
communicate with the clients regarding
requirement clearly otherwise the entire
project May collapse as a business
analyst facilitating meetings is very
important it's a plus point to boost
your confidence if you have good
communication skill
database and SQL every business analyst
must have hands-on experience on SQL
they most oftenly work on structured
data bus business analysts must be well
versed in Oracle DB MySQL and no SQL
databases
next is programming skills it's better
to know programming languages like
python or r as it is extremely
beneficial in solving problems with the
help of the above mentioned programming
language it will become easy to analyze
and visualize larger forms of data
Microsoft Excel this is the basic skill
that every industry demands from a
business analyst Excel is one of the
strongest analytical tools business
analyst uses to perform calculations day
and data records I repeat and data
records They analyze and summarize data
using pivot tables they create charts
and analyze the data using Microsoft
Excel
having documentation and presentation
skill is very crucial a business analyst
might document their project very
precisely they should confidently
present their project outcomes with the
stakeholders
creating reports and dashboards business
analysts must be able to operate various
business intelligence tools for the
creation of reports and dashboards these
reports are mainly created to solve
decision making problems coming to tools
used by business analyst we have covered
some of the important tools frequently
used by business analyst Chira or
conference the collaboration tools jira
and Confluence are very effective to
collaborate effectively on project and
share requirements every business
analyst has to be least familiar with
jira by using platforms like jira and
Confluence all business stakeholders May
engage with various teams and view the
status of the project
hello is a project management platform
that businesses use for teamwork and
task organization work into columns on a
board it enables you to manage your
projects and efforts by dividing
complicated project into smaller more
manageable and realizable chunks of
Labor this helps to simplify and
standardize your work
Microsoft Visual project management and
business modeling are two areas where
Microsoft Visual excels it may be used
to make data models project timelines
process flowcharts use case diagrams and
money mode
Google Docs you may be familiar with
Google Docs Google Docs provides you
with templates for business research
business analyst may share and
collaborate on documents effectively
using Google Docs with the use of Google
docs business analyst can communicate
with stakeholders about any kind of file
or document next is how to become
business analyst if you are a fresher
this part is for you firstly it is very
important to decide your goal
understanding the fundamentals and
choosing the right path is very
important in every feed start learning
fundamentals of business analyst first
start and then Master it
show the related degree choose the right
bachelor degree you can take up a
business management degree and take a
course related to the subject and do
check out the course regarding business
analyst from Simply learn in the
description box below
develop the business analytical skill
that we have mentioned in the previous
section start working on it
real-time projects on Business
Development and analytics and lastly
apply for job build a portfolio include
your practical experience the portfolio
should consider all the internships and
projects you will be qualified to apply
for a job after you get all the
experience necessary coming to
responsibilities and roles a business
analyst has a variety of responsibility
and role therefore it is crucial to have
a thorough understanding of the
responsibilities and roles held by a
business analyst before learning how to
become one analyst pinpoints the goals
and issue of a company's business and
develops profitable Solutions
the assemble stakeholder and business
requirements
business analysts collaborate with the
business development team to create plan
for addressing a specific issue business
analysts aggressively offer feedback on
the design of a software program and
integrate the newly created features
that company needs business analyst also
evaluate functional and non-functional
requirements different roles performed
by business analysts are data analyst
business architect system analyst and
product manager coming to top companies
hiring business analyst are Accenture
IBM Infosys TCS Deloitte VMware Etc now
coming to most important part salary of
a business analyst
in U.S freshers the average salary of a
business analyst will be seventy
thousand dollars per annum and if you
are experienced you will be starting
with eighty thousand dollars per annum
it can go up to 1 lakh thousand dollars
average salary of a business analyst in
India the salary of a business analyst
in India will range from 4 lakh to 20
lakh
for refresher the average salary is 4
lakh and for experienced it can go up to
15 lakh and it can exceed up to 20 to 30
lakhs also
this is the demand for business analyst
all over the world you are now prepared
to begin your career in business
analytics because you have a better
understanding of what business analyst
does their roles and responsibility and
the steps involved in becoming one I
hope this video was helpful thank you
for watching and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here